hey guys so today marks the one-year
anniversary of this channel our tip
encase Channel yes yay happy birthday
Channel so we actually wanted to sit
down and make this video for you guys
kind of just talk about the impact that
this channel has made in our lives and
the reason why we started this channel
in the first place first and foremost
you have to thank you guys because
without you guys and without a constant
interaction the words of encouragement
that we get from you guys I feel like we
probably wouldn't keep up with the
channel as often as we would and we
should actually keep up the channel more
because I know you guys want us to
upload more often but we really really
wish we could but honestly like our
schedules are insane and you know if you
guys don't know this we actually work
with another YouTube channel I'm just
kidding films just kidding news just get
the party so we that's like our main job
and so that's why I like for this
channel even though we wish we could
just go like upload daily upload
everything but hopefully in the future
that will change and we can somehow make
things work out in our schedule so we
can really just give this channel more
for this coming year I want to upload
twice as often yeah so we're kind of
putting it out there so we can like hold
ourselves to it as well if you guys
don't know TIFF is actually the one that
wanted to start the channel without her
I don't think this channel would exist
so reason why I wanted to start the
channel is because I was working with JK
you know over the years we kind of like
gained our own personal following and so
because of you guys out there that kept
asking us like we want to see a channel
from Tim in case you know we want to see
your guys's lives you want to see the
key I've seen like we want to see what
we can't see through JK so then that's
why I like I've kind of brought it up to
Kacie and I'm like hey you know what
like there's all these fans out there
that they really want to get to know us
some more like maybe we should start our
own channel
and he wanted to do cooking videos but
it's so funny but because of our and
thing schedule it's been hard I'm gonna
cook Eve is that we don't know all your
all your three no I take the lots of
prep for a cooking video when it comes
to cooking
there's the cooking that happens without
a camera and you're like okay I gotta
this is easy the timing works out when
you have the camera
the lights and then you're trying to
like think about what you're gonna say
because you don't usually explain your
process as you're cooking that slows
everything down and then what you're
supposed to be a 30-minute cook ends up
being like five hours and then it
doesn't turn out that great because in
all the timings off and like you know
you're too worried about the camera but
then you have to worry about the food
but because I was gonna make good movie
tours and you were supposed to vlog by
way of that I guess I ended up helping
you with the vlogging stuff as well and
I actually don't like vlogging I
actually I never watch vlogs I hated
vlogs for the longest time because I
just thought they were boring to watch
Casey hated being in front of the camera
I did so how did like this whole year of
us having our channel how does that like
help you break out of that I think I may
add nature's repetition just constantly
talking to this camera here this is
daunting I don't know why it just scares
me it just makes me feel nervous but I
feel I felt the exact same way too and I
first started working with JK because
that was my first experience being in
front of a camera at all I remember I
was like wanna hide in my own little
show and like no don't look at me the
lens is looking at me it's not scary but
I think blogging alone has been very
liberating because of all those problems
that we had prior to that I guess
vlogging and starting the channel I
think this channel has remedied all
those problems for us and I don't feel
like I'm the same Casey as I was a year
ago I feel the same way like I feel like
it helped me gain a lot of confidence as
well but the thing that's most important
to me though the main main main reason
why I wanted to start the channel was to
immortalize Isaac's childhood and our
relationship and like seeing ourselves
grow and like just picturing ourselves
like watching this video like 20 years
from now and then seeing how how much
has changed
that's a beautiful part of this channel
like that I hold close to my heart you
guys don't know this I was actually like
a huge fan of Casey before we even met
because I saw his work when he saw work
he used to make videos for wax and
dumfounded and before I even discovered
JK and so I would always see like how
amazing
he was with his work like Kristen with
tog Rafi the editing like everything I
was just always such a fan and I like to
have him do like edit like my life in my
son's life and our life together if
that's another beautiful thing I I feel
really lucky that I have like the whole
package right here remember our first
video yeah it was a 66 night market I
that was my first time ever attempting
at vlogging what you guys don't know is
that she wanted that as a cat Esther
like she just wanted to practice
vlogging in that day and I was like oh
you shot that might as well just edited
yeah that's so true cuz I remember it
like as I was like I think that's why I
came off so natural I guess because like
there's a lot of people that were saying
Michael you're such a natural blogger
but I think it was because I had in my
mind now that I remember you know state
had in my mind like oh this is just like
just for us like no one's really gonna
watch it and I think that's when I had
like more confidence to just be like so
look at this and look at that and let me
talk to the camera and let me like not
care about anyone else watching me in
public like talking about camera I guess
yeah I totally forgot about that I did
not want to upload that you know what
I'm actually really grateful we have
this channel for another reason because
before this channel this is horror
vacations with pan out Casey would be
really stressed because he had like
deadlines he had to me there's a lot of
editing every time like without fail
every every vacation we've ever taken
every time we have to fly out somewhere
there's always happen if we're going on
a vacation I want him to unplug and just
forget about the the stress like we'll
get back to it when we come back but
don't bring that with us and I remember
like for example we went to Cancun and
in Cancun I forbid him from bringing
Computers now it's like launcher I'm
like you are not working we're in Cancun
we have to relax we have to enjoy this
and so the whole time I just kept
hearing him complain like I feel like
I'm not doing anything I feel like I
need to get work done I need it and
that's the beauty of him like because
because of this I think you love your
work so much
I'm a workaholic I think that's that's a
good thing but it's not good when it
like consumes your life to that point
where we're on vacation and like you
can't let go I feel like I always need
to keep my mind busy you know and like
if it's not busy I feel like it's a
waste now because like when we go out in
vacation now you're happy because you're
working by filming our vacations are so
much more happier because of that like
for example like the first vacation we
took starting this channel with Hawaii
we went for part and gos wedding oh my
god Superior Court it's so much footage
there yeah what happened we accidentally
deleted some footage yeah so the way the
camera would send it I mean there's like
the technicality before we were still
learning the camera and then I think
going through through different friends
on in terms of their preferences on how
the camera should be set up the footage
was split into several different folders
and we only pulled a portion of it out
yeah so the actual wedding footage god
but you know what I don't even feel that
bad because all of our friends are
vloggers so that day was still captured
even through like someone else's
perspective so it's not that huge of a
loss but it did I cried like when I
realized I lost that footage like it hit
me because it was like that was like
through through our perspective you know
like we can't get that put into that but
it's okay if it's already done and then
we moved on then you move on so what's
it like seeing Isaac girls in front of
the camera awesome I wish like my
parents would have had video of me when
I was little I mean I do have like a
handful of photos it's not
much but so I always wish like I could
like document my own kid's life and so
as soon as I started coming around JK
and like I think I've been able to be in
a lot of skits and that you see him a
little five-year-old
Isaac and it's like the darkest it
started at five yeah and I feel like we
started at a good time - at seven
because it is at seven we were still
able to capture the tail end of little
kid years yeah and now I feel like we're
entering the big kid here yes you know
so I feel like it was a very good time
to guess to capture the essence of the
little kid Isaac and now we're starting
to see the big kid Isaac we're on
vacation I actually focused like the
camera on Isaac a lot more because I
kind of I feel like seeing him see that
world that we're visiting at that time
speaks way more than pointedly camreta
ourselves and like from the adult
perspective Oh Isaac sighs it's like wow
you know I think when we went to Japan
yeah they go is such a culture shock for
Isaac and like to actually have that
forever in the video and like he can
look back on that too and like say like
I remember moving to Japan
I remember experienced a guy that's that
remember when we literally came back
from Japan we're tired and then like two
days later on a plane yeah yeah right
after we went to Texas and we went to go
spend like Christmas ears and how does
it feel like for you to actually like
vlog your own family like it was weird I
have to say like at that time I was
already getting sort of used to vlogging
and I was like oh cool like I'm already
expanding what my opinion was on
vlogging and then I was starting to get
more comfortable with the camera as well
of myself then when we got to Dallas I
was like now I have to integrate one
more element that I'm not too sure if
I'm comfortable with which was pointing
the camera at my family which I've never
done before but you know what actually
eased it in my family yeah you're like
never like super like I gonna blog cool
okay and then they were just they kind
of went right with is maybe they weren't
weird about it that like his parents
think
you see them on camera it's how they are
in person like they don't turn it on or
turn it off or shy away or try to like
overcompensate for who they are like
that's just what you see is what you get
and that's I love that about your
parents they're awesome when you're able
to see who they are through video it's
almost kind of like a chance for you to
really soak it who they are because I
didn't realize how cool my parents were
so I saw them on video and I was like
hey my parents are cool you don't
reflect on that in the day to day
interactions with someone when we went
to Mexico and like capturing like our
families colliding and thinking how
accepting they were of each other like
oh my god that like hits me am I good so
beautiful like they're so beautiful like
hell they just accept each other and
like and then for us to actually like
capture that in video and like we can
forever hold that with us so another big
thing that happened this year was our
move moved homes we're here now
why did we move because if it was up to
me we would never move why did we go be
forced to pay to move literally you did
I convinced you yeah so in our old home
it was a duplex so picture like one huge
home and then cut it down the middle
we had one side we had neighbors on the
other side the flow was elevated it was
wooden floor we kept hearing a lot of
noise it was just a lot of unpleasant
banging them at home in terms of like
the noise complaints and then we were
pretty close to like our surroundings in
the neighborhood were really loud and
there was no like because we had one
half of the home the other half had no
sunlight and we had a detached garage so
we park in the garage we had to walk
through and so like every time it would
be raining we had to go down like the
elements and it was just a lot of like
little inconveniences that we didn't
realize how much it impacted
add it up and I heard up a lot so after
our landlords let us know that the rent
was gonna be going up and that he was
going to be moving and it was just like
a lot of little things I finally have to
talking to you after like you know
trying to convince you like let's try to
see if we can find somewhere at least
cheaper maybe or like an upgrade
so then after searching we found this
one home and like I fell in love with
that home like oh my god this is the
place we need to live it's amazing it's
perfect and then they've denied us I
think they they thought we were too
young to have a home yeah so we kept
looking and we found this place and I
was like it's actually pretty good so
the thing is like though we really
wanted we wanted like a standalone home
we don't want to have neighbors so then
that's that wasn't one thing we were
trying to escape is not that have
neighbors we don't want it I didn't
personally I get really really mad when
I hear other people talking through the
walls or I hear likes footsteps or
thumps or music someone's playing music
amazed or inaction moving you can hear
like just ever like ever so slowly that
I am an old man I'm just I can't I can't
deal with that noise because it's too
insignificant to tell what it is but
then it's too significant to not hear it
either so it's just like in this
in-between of like you're there but I
can't I don't know what it is so it's
like this firm we find this place and
it's like 99% I feel and like just that
1% was the fact that it's not a
standalone home because like this is
technically like a condo so there's we
had we do have neighbors on the side so
then we're like well let's go check it
out let's see what it what it's all
about and we get here we're like this is
perfect this is it this is the place so
then we applied and luckily like you
know we got accepted and I don't know
what they put in between the walls but
it's silent I never ever hear as I said
we don't have neighbors it's awesome
it's so funny that likes just one small
change
like that like changing our home
actually impacted us a lot because as
soon as we moved here we were like so
much more happier we're able to like
focus on our relationship and our
relationship actually blossomed a lot
more moving to the track because we were
so we argued a lot at the old house and
we don't show you the arguments in blogs
but we argue a lot and we still do
occasionally but anything really
yeah it's only natural people people are
humans humans are people but here like
we're just so happy that like there's
very little things for us to even be
upset about and the next thing that came
after that during this year it was this
thing I don't see it it's not big enough
we had been talking about getting
married in the future and all that and
so you know you'd ask me like so what
would be like your ideal proposal like
what like pick me the scenario and I'm
like honestly I have no idea the only
the one and only thing I ask of you is
that please make sure it's captured on
camera cuz like I want to be able to
like see my reaction see that moment and
like just forever have it and then the
moment you said that are IID knew
exactly how I needed the propose because
I was like well she's she's gonna know
the cameras there if I said the camera
up and I proposed to her so she's gonna
see it coming and I was like what's the
perfect ideal location and time and
space to propose her with cameras going
where she won't think the cameras are
set up and something that's what the
happen and I was like hey news there's
three years of rolling all
simultaneously and it's gonna capture
everything our friends already they're
like everything has already set in place
well when it comes to the idea of doing
a proposal or JK news yeah and honestly
I had that never crossed my mind
I had never in a million years would've
thought that you would propose while I
worked
so the moment would actually happen
unlikely what no yeah walk me through
this like our number poles of video we
never really detailed your thought
process it was a lot from my perspective
and you were just kinda like the subject
of the video
alright so walk me through the process
so I remember it was like midnight and I
was so bummed out because that was the
day of our anniversary it's all before
this when I was getting ready in the
morning to go to taking news I was
planning on wearing my secured shirt so
I told Katie I'm like oh yeah I'm gonna
wear my secure shirt I haven't worn it
to taking news yet he was like well
why'd you wear something nicer like just
dress up a little nicer and I'm like and
I'm in my head I was thinking well maybe
when I get home from from JK news he's
probably gonna set up like a really nice
dinner cuz it's our anniversary
something okay I'll entertain it so I
get all cute I see already haven't had
some sort of yeah I had no idea
anniversary not the proposal yeah so you
got saved because of that cuz then later
on he tells to you I can't I told her to
change in G I was like no you really did
she's gonna suspect it cuz she she
catches on to these things quickly but I
didn't even suspect though it was around
midnight and I remember texting you and
I'm just like Oh baby I'm so sorry we
just have one one more article Labs like
oh my god I just want to go home already
head over I mean I'm actually in the
back room waiting to about the proposed
and I'm like one more home I cut that to
me so then Tim starts reading off this
fake article which I thought was real
and so I remember like him saying like
you know through Korean barbecue nights
and like she's a wonderful mother and
things like that and I was just like
that sounds just like us so then I was
like wait a minute
and that moment when I said wait a
minute I think I felt like I was
dreaming like it just felt surreal cuz I
was like wait and is this happening
right now like are they really talking
to and I didn't think of an a proposal
it was just the fact that this story
sounded just like my life that Beth said
I don't know does that make sense like I
was hearing that I felt like I was
dreaming like it wasn't real that was my
intention though you succeeded baby you
did because I had no clue so then once
they said that nobody reacted around me
everyone was like oh like just continue
to listen to Tim so I was thinking like
that maybe I'm trippin like did I hear
everything right because I think you
guys don't know this but sometimes when
we weren't like during JK news and like
the if Julia is hosting I'm not there
like hosting right so I don't know what
the story is gonna be about
so whenever the guest is reading the
description sometimes I like zone out
and so I don't catch everything that
they're saying so then they then that's
why I like when they will talk about the
article and I'll ask about like I'll ask
a question that was already answered
during the headline but that's because I
kind of zone l when I'm Andre can you
say I so I'm not so often I'm just like
where yeah where are we know that's
that's a problem and then like further
websites clues of others like a
discussion that's how you realize well
we're sucking we fill so many articles
inhaling we do like 40 articles so in
that's like the very last one I'm tired
I want to go home Tim is reading and I'm
picking up little things are you saying
I'm like wait that sounds like me so I
was like wait a minute nobody reacts so
I'm thinking man maybe I missed
something you know what baby so not the
entire time
yes the land Tim keeps reading and I
tried to see geo and I see that she's
trying to hide behind the three cameras
are set up in the center so I can't see
her face I'm like what's happening and
then everyone starts looking at me
because Tim stopped reading and then I'm
like is everyone looking at me wait
what's happening and then I see Gio pop
your head out quick she's like crying
already
and I see her looking behind me and I'm
like wait what and I turn around and I
see you there and I'm like wait what I
had no clue like it was just like
surreal I know it was surreal it was so
surreal that I actually didn't propose
yeah he never once asked me will you
marry me ever and you know what's so
funny so after that happened like you
know the entire proposal we all
celebrated he tells me you never said
yes in that moment I didn't realize that
you never asked me I didn't either out
it's kind of like you didn't say yes so
then I'm just like yes and then we get
home that night we realized like we
don't you didn't even ask me like to say
if you know I will you marry me or
anything but not until that night
welcome to have been I'm like nasty in
the nuts of me ask me will you marry me
not again okay like when I was walking
up from behind you I was I didn't feel
like I was it was real
oh nothing felt real in those moments
leading up and because it didn't feel
real I guess I just forgot that past you
well you marry me I just got down on one
knee and started smiling
alright guys thanks for watching this
video of our one-year anniversary we
really hope you've enjoyed the ride with
us so far and we're looking forward to
more years to come and we're gonna try
it upload more frequently for you guys
to guys I know you guys want to see more
videos from us so try our best to get
these videos done and out to you and
we're gonna try and expand our channel
to include more segments on this channel
such as my segment I don't know what to
call it but yeah we've already mentioned
this in our previous videos that you
know that's something that's in the
works so stay tuned for that
and see you guys in the next video
[Music]